former president Barack Obama still on
the campaign Trail still absolutely
crushing a lot of the horrible people
that are running this time around most
recently uh former president Obama was
in the state of Nevada Nevada is a place
that has a very important race going on
it is a race that is not necessarily
going that well for the Democrat the
Republican running is Adam laxalt a
horrible horrible person uh this is a
Nevada Senate and the Democratic
candidate is Catherine Cortez masto
unfortunately Adam LAX salt has opened
up a roughly two-point lead roughly
two-point lead 1.9 percentage points
over masto and he is an absolutely
horrible horrible candidate former
president Barack Obama Obama yeah right
right we know his real name he called
out the rising anti-Semitism that we are
seeing he correctly identified that the
rhetoric that led to Paul Pelosi being
attacked is likely to do more damage and
to cause more violence let's listen to a
few of these clips speaking very
precisely on these issues
[Music]
people log on to that I want to give you
a tip Nevada yep
I I I want to give you a tip if you see
or read something on the Internet
that says some people certain kinds of
people
whether it's whether it's white or black
or immigrant or
gay
or Jew
or Muslim when you see
something on the Internet that says
those people are the cause of your
problems
that that is that is a dangerous lie
[Applause]
fat
that is a path
that will tear this country apart yeah
and it's not just we'll tear the country
apart but it's will also lead to
significantly more violence and in this
next clip
former president Obama makes that point
very clear as well
a friend of mine Mr Paul Pelosi
was attacked viciously somebody broke
into his home looking for his wife Nancy
Pelosi the Speaker of the House
and thankfully I spoke to Paul a couple
days ago and I he's going to be okay
but
but it but even as investigators do
their job find out what exactly
motivated this this person one thing's
clear
this increasing habit of demonizing
political opponents
creates a dangerous climate
and and elected officials who do not
explicitly reject
or participate in over the top rhetoric
if that's what they're doing instead of
it it if if they just ignore
or make light
of that kind of violence
or if they encourage their supporters to
stand outside voting places armed with
guns and dressed in tactical gear yes if
that's the environment that we create
more people are going to get hurt and
remember
generically condemning violence when
there is violence but then continuing to
do campaign ads where there's Targets on
people or to say at campaign rallies
someone should really do something about
Nancy Pelosi this is a really big
difference between the left and the
right in the United States
the right will say
black lives matter is violent and they
threaten people or antifa does this that
or the other thing when you look at the
top level of the people in positions of
power you do not see the violent
rhetoric from the left the way that you
see from the right
it's what it is the left doesn't talk
about knocking them around alluding to
violence but playing Coy the left
doesn't regularly use campaign ads with
people holding Firearms or putting
Targets on the backs of individuals
I know that we can find in a country of
330 million anecdotes of everything but
the right specifically the Maga right
Mitt Romney really doesn't do this that
I've ever seen him do
I've not seen Liz Cheney do it I've not
seen Adam kinzinger do it but the Maga
right
is doing this deliberately
and it's not it might lead to violence
anymore it's it has led to violence it
has led to violence
Barack Obama also weighing in very
clearly on the stakes here when it comes
to policy that affects people versus
cultural issues that are contrived and
used to drive wedges between individuals
the question though you should be asking
is who's going to actually try to do
something about it right
because if you watch these ads
Republicans they talk about it a lot but
what's their answer exactly what what is
their Economic Policy none
tax cuts for the rich I guess no no they
they've got one
they want to gut Social Security
and Medicare
and then give
their wealthy friends and big
corporations more tax cuts right
because
and because that's their answer to
everything
that's I I'm not joking literally it
does not matter what's going on
when inflation is low and unemployment
is high
they want tax cuts
when it's the reverse
tax cuts
I I was telling some folks in Michigan
if there was an asteroid headed towards
Earth right now
they'd all get in the room they say you
know what you need you we gotta cut
taxes for the wealthy
that that's going to solve it
really
I mean I guess it's simple
to just have one answer to every
economic problem exactly
I remember
you know when I when I had a test in
math and and uh sometimes I I didn't
study hard enough
I might have stayed up too late the
night before and it'd be nice if you
could just write down eight
on for every answer yeah I mean this is
just a version of when all you have is a
hammer everything looks like a nail or
you claim it's a nail even if it's
something completely different and
former president Obama is completely
right in that and he actually goes
further and again this is not about
glorifying Republicans of times past
it's not that Reagan was great or bush
by dear God it's not that Bush was great
either it's that there has been a real
observable tangible change in the way
that this political party the Republican
Party operates
on the one hand you've got politicians
who seem like they won't do anything and
say anything
to get power
and leaders who share our values who
want to make your lives better
who want to move the country forward
and and let me say this Nevada
they
you know one of the difficult things
about these kinds of rally these days is
is
sometimes
this this seems so partisan as if it's
just a Democrat Republican thing my
favorite President is a guy named Abe
Lincoln
who helped found the Republican Party
it used to be that
there were GOP members who championed
progress and civil rights and that was
longer ago than Bush to be clear
but these days just about every
Republican politician seems obsessed
with two things
owning the lips and getting Donald
Trump's approval
for now for now and as we spoke about
with Angelo Carrison yesterday
the desperation for Trump's approval May
Wane depending on how next Tuesday goes
and depending on what happens with
Trump's 2024 candidacy if there is one
last clip from Obama
he weighs in on Election fraud Adam lack
salt the candidate that he is
campaigning against in Nevada is a big
lie proponent
and here is what President Obama says
he has no actual evidence of election
fraud because
there's actually no widespread election
fraud but he's not going to let that
stop him absolutely he's gonna look
under every Rock in the desert to try to
find an excuse
although if he wins I'm guessing he'll
be less concerned
all those votes will be legit funny how
that works
listen I lost my first congressional
Race by 30 points I got whooped
you know you know what I did not do
I didn't say this was right
I didn't claim fraud
I certainly didn't instigate
a riot on the capitol
instead I asked myself
how can I be better yeah good luck
getting Republicans to ask themselves
that question and of course he's
completely and totally correct if you
vote in Nevada
if you vote in Nevada we do not want
Senator Adam laxalt and we have the
potential to see Senator Adam laxalt and
Senator Herschel Walker
and Senator Mehmet Oz and Governor Kerry
Lake
and a republican governor in Oregon
whose name I forget for the first time
since 1987.
this could get very dark very very
quickly
and so we have to vote we have to vote
is the message I know it's repetitive
but it is a must do
the chances that your login credentials
have been leaked in a data breach are
higher than you might think but you can
actually check if you go to aura.com
Pacman you can try Aura for free our
sponsor Aura scans the dark web for your
personal information login credentials
social security number and sends you
alerts sign up and you could be shocked
to see how many alerts you get on Aura
one of our team members found his login
credentials in three different data
breaches now of course he changed his
passwords right away I've told you
before about one of my accounts getting
hacked scary feeling but Aura also does
so much more by automatically requesting
the removal of information from data
search engines giving you fast alerts on
suspicious credit inquiries Aura has
password management malware protection
for all of your devices and Aura also
helps you manage what your kids can do
on their devices by restricting certain
apps it's really like a Swiss army knife
of online security and you can try Aura
for free for two weeks at aura.com
Pacman the link is down below